take a look at the roofs of these four
houses can you spot which one is covered
in solar cells that's a trick question
because they all are
Tesla just unveiled its first ever solar
product and it's stunning
it's not a solar panel instead it's a
range of for solar roofing materials
that look virtually indistinguishable
from high-end terracotta
slate or slick modern asphalt shingles
people really care about their homes
they love their homes and they really
want them to be better and I think
taking this approach it can be
here's how it works the top of the roof
tile is made of textured glass it looks
like shingles from most angles but it
allows sunlight to pass through from
above and into a standard solar cell
with almost no loss in efficiency
Tesla says the glass is as tough as
steel and can weather a lifetime of
abuse from the elements it can also be
fitted with heating elements to melt off
snow and colder climates you want to
call your neighbors over and say check
out check out the sweet roof it's like
our phrase that you hear often it this
represents the grand unification of
Tesla's plans to become a Sun to vehicle
energy company the idea is that you can
run your home on solar power store it in
a slim battery that hangs on your wall
and then use that electricity to power
your home and car Tesla also doubled the
capacity of that power wall battery
creating the world's cheapest
lithium-ion storage to extend rooftop
solar power into the night this
combination is perhaps the closest we've
ever come to affordable off-grid
electricity though musk was still a
little fuzzy on the pricing details the
goal is to make solar roofs that look
better than a normal roof generate
electricity out last longer a better
insulation and actually have an
installed cost that is less than a
normal roof plus the cost of electricity
so then why would you buy anything else
the solar roof was Musk's closing
argument to shareholders before their
vote to approve Tesla's 2.2 billion
dollar bid to buy the biggest u.s.
rooftop solar installer Solar City to
make it all possible
there are plenty of reasons to be
skeptical but if muss can pull it off
this trifecta of Tesla products the
solar roof the power wall - and the
model 3 electric car will be available
in Tesla stores across the u.s. at the
end of 2017
you